if you were stuck in a disaster zone
where the entire country is sinking into
the ground what would you do when help
is nowhere to be found you'll have to do
the most savage things to stay alive i'm
here to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to be the
deadly earthquakes in japan sinks 2020
this whole city is about to be destroyed
muto here is training to be a star
athlete with a group of other wannabe
hopefuls while listening to their coach
they noticed something wrong the ground
beneath them starts to shake and that's
when they realize that a small
earthquake has just hit their city but
what they don't realize is that this is
the beginning of something much more
terrifying the athletes are getting
ready to go home when suddenly everyone
receives a text on their phone telling
them that another earthquake is coming
and this time it's going to be much
worse okay first things first you get a
warning about an earthquake on your
phone which means you better bunker down
under some tables or find something
strong to hide under we're in a locker
room which doesn't give me any
confidence that we're making it out of
here in one piece lockers are big and
heavy and if they fall on top of us
we're dead realistically we don't have
much time and we already felt a minor
earthquake which means i would leave
this room immediately find some cover in
the nearest available room or a desk big
enough to hide my handsome self under
the most important thing in an
earthquake is to keep your head covered
while losing your limbs isn't an ideal
scenario it's better than being dead
either way they shouldn't have headed
back to their locker rooms as soon as
they did this will cost them everything
but you know what won't cost you
everything raid shadow legends this game
will literally teach you how to avoid
the worst of the worst with their global
pvp and absolutely massive pve boss
battles and over 600 championships i
might add into larry we've got two kinds
of else we have the normal
run-of-the-mill high elves they're kind
of boring you should go with the siroth
elves the dark elves they're so freaking
cool the dark elves 700 years ago got
tempted by syrah who tempted them with
art and philosophy but the arbiter
begged them to stop but they were too
cool for her resulting in war that the
high elves won but not without a
never-ending back and forth power
struggle lasting centuries they're like
a legion of evil assassins and warlocks
and my go-to stud is the dark elf sniper
with her super cool reign of arrow skill
i can slow my enemies down while i take
them out permanently you need to use
strategy in order to survive and in this
game you can set the strategy to
whatever level you like they've got a
jam packed halloween lineup coming up
that i am so excited for you guys it is
so freaking cool from major tournaments
to special fragments that'll even get
you some brand freaking new legendary
champions click the link in the
description or scan my qr code so you'll
get the epic hero chenoru along with 200
can silver one xp boost one energy
refill and one ancient shard so you can
summon an awesome champion as soon as
you enter the game the rewards will only
be available for the next 30 days and
only for new players you can find me
in-game under anime can be and if you're
fast enough maybe you can join my clan
click the link in the description and
i'll see you in game thank you ray for
sponsoring this video now back to the
story and that's when all hell breaks
loose the entire room begins to
violently shake and everything starts to
fall apart stunned by the earthquake
muto wakes up to a deadly surprise all
of her fellow classmates have been
brutally crushed and she's the only one
still alive broken skulls and intestines
are everywhere in shock she runs away
from the carnage that just ensued but
that's not all the whole city is being
completely destroyed by the massive
earthquake buildings are falling planes
are crashing and thousands upon
thousands of people are already dead
later on muto makes it out of the
stadium and into the outskirts of the
city with no way to contact her friends
or family she's lost and has nowhere to
go holy moly guacamole now i know that
they were only a few feet away in their
locker rooms when [ __ ] hit the fan a
second time but honestly all these
tragic accidents could have been avoided
if they just applied existing knowledge
about earthquakes to begin with this is
japan after all a country well prepared
for the 2 000 plus earthquakes they have
per year yeah per year if that is the
case then these people should have been
highly educated for disaster scenarios
the japanese school curriculum prepares
citizens from birth to act in an orderly
manner when these situations happen
getting caught off guard by the initial
rumblings of an earthquake can happen
but they should have waited before
heading inside to the locker rooms as
they were already in one of the safest
spots they could have been an open-air
stadium by design these stadiums would
have allowed people to huddle to its
center away from any falling buildings
or objects also they should have waited
longer before heading inside due to
aftershocks and these can occur up to an
hour after the initial rumblings it's
not like they had anywhere better to be
tokyo's buildings themselves are made to
withstand 9.0 earthquakes and above so
it's unlikely in this instance that this
stadium would have collapsed from the
inside and speaking of those locker
rooms from within that locker room
should have been bolted down to begin
with this is common practice with many
buildings and within people's homes in
japan to prevent this sort of thing from
happening the school definitely screwed
up on this one while it might seem
cold-blooded muto here ditching her
classmates was the right call let's be
honest she's no medically trained
professional and did you see that horror
show there were more dead teenagers than
a slasher movie the chance of more
rubble falling from the ceiling is
pretty dang high so if it were me i
would sprint like sonic on speed and
hightail it right out of that locker
room and find someone better equipped to
take care of the situation this ain't no
wonder woman film people this is real
life sorta on the off chance the
internet was down muto could still have
sent or received a recorded message to
her family using japan's ntt disaster
message board service which is an analog
messaging service in japan where people
can leave recorded messages for other
people to check around the world this
could also give her the ability to check
for any incoming messages left by her
family members assuming they're still
alive suddenly muto notices fluorescent
lights on top of a nearby hill right
beneath the shinto shrine realizing the
lights are the same ones her dad likes
she rushes to the top and finally
reunites with her dad and that's when
one of her fellow athletes shows up
along with her little injured brother go
the mom joins in on the surprise
reuniting the whole family with
everything going back to normal suddenly
a mangled body drops from the tree and
people start falling from the sky and
that's when they notice a helicopter
instantly crash into the city's center
however this is only the beginning
nearly everyone here is going to die and
no one is safe from the deadly
earthquakes if there was an olympic
competition for the scariest freaking
country on earth right now then japan
would have had the 59th medal to their
collection cause this is insanity we
have enough problems dealing with
earthquakes and tsunamis and now we have
to fend off falling corpses too talk
about unsanitary if they reach terminal
velocity then we're looking at 190
kilometers per hour solid objects
crashing down on us and i'm sorry not
even mary poppins umbrella could save
our asses i would look to hide under the
tree line right there as this could have
been our best defense to wait out the
human rainstorm mutu got really lucky
realizing where her dad would be but in
reality they should have already had
designated meetup points for situations
like this outside their houses for after
earthquakes and outside their
neighborhood for bigger earthquake
disasters and once again 2 000 plus
earthquakes a year people 2 000 plus
you'd think they'd have known better the
dad played it smart with that emergency
kit he was rocking and once again he
could have told you that having an
emergency disaster kit with important
provisions like food and first aid
should have already been prepared in
advance at least one of them was
thinking with their heads spending their
first day on the hill the group wakes up
to bad news the water has risen above
sea level and their chances of surviving
are getting smaller by the day checking
the internet everyone begins to realize
that the whole of japan is being
demolished the whole island of okinawa
has sunk due to the rising sea levels
and the rest of japan is soon to follow
with no other options the father gathers
everyone together and they head through
the town to find somewhere safer stuck
at a crossroads they have two options go
westwards towards okinawa or head east
towards ibaraki one of the men tells the
group that he has a distribution center
full of food and resources needed for
survival however go's online friend from
estonia here texts him and says that
going west is the safer option so the
family decides to listen to a kid from
halfway across the world and head west
while the rest of the group decides to
head east hold on we need to pump the
brakes a little bit because what our
options are either head west in the
direction of a place that doesn't even
exist anymore or head east where some
guy has a distribution center full of
food and shelter and the family wants to
go west this is one of those instances
where i feel the need to comment
politely to our anime group's fictional
intellect why are you all so stupid this
is the perfect example of human error at
its finest aside from the dad's medkit
they have no provisions no food they
barely have any water and yet they're
willing to trust the friend of a child
who's not even in the same country as
them right now idiot we don't know
what's going on so we need to conserve
what battery have left and go's online
social life can wait now both moves on
where to go are a gamble so we should
apply a little common sense here the
direction heading down to okinawa has
lower lying land than the east or even
central japan which has on average the
highest points of elevation compared to
the rest of japan if the land is sinking
which it is it wouldn't make sense to
head to lower lying land also heading
directly to the epicenter of the
earthquake is where most of the damage
will have taken place as this is where
the hypocenter or focus of the
earthquake would have begun which means
stuff there including buildings and
resources will be worse off than
anywhere else it also wouldn't be a bad
idea to get familiarized with this group
and figure out what skill sets they have
we're much better in a group than solo
and this is a chance to find out what
everybody is good at are any of them
hunters or nurses doctors this is the
time to get friendly with everybody and
if all goes to hell then i'd see if i
could convince the second group to
simply head west instead as this way i
could have the distribution center to
myself what can i say i need it more on
the way there we need to look for
weaponry as people tend to have a bad
habit of doing terrible things when
pushed to the edge which may just happen
very soon walking on the highway muto
notices two old people in need worried
for their safety she decides to give
them the family's last remaining water
bottle what a nice girl worried about
being at sea level the family heads for
the mountains suddenly they find a
nearby creek full of fresh drinking
water this is a gold mine this right
here is money since muto decided to give
away all our water which is priceless at
the moment this is the best thing we've
seen in a while which is why we can't
afford to let this go to waste if i was
them i would stay here pretty much as
long as i could or at least for a longer
time than they did we have replenishing
water and we could in theory forge for
various nuts and berries and mountain
crap that is native to japan such as
butterbur ostrich fern flowering
rapeseed spring chrysanthemum among
other things earthquakes don't last
forever and if they are this far away
from everything and low on supplies i
would seriously consider staying here
for at least a night or two until they
have more information to work with
consider it a bonus that they are high
up and away from tall structures later
that day the family heads past ruined
towns and deserted areas but luckily
they managed to find and catch some pork
grub for the night not knowing that one
of them is going to die the very next
day that morning the group finds a sign
that says there are japanese yams in the
nearby area the father decides to go
digging so they have dinner for the
coming night that's when muto notices
something very sinister they've
completely ignored one of the signs and
guess what it says unexploded minds
could be buried here suddenly the father
makes one last dig and a mine explodes
right on the spot killing him instantly
and ridding the family of a father
forever the group decides to keep on
heading west while they cope with the
crazy [ __ ] that just happened luckily
for them a cheeky trucker comes by and
lets them hitch a ride but this ride
isn't for free stopping at a gas station
the athlete here goes to wash her hands
when suddenly the trucker comes by and
tries to attack her mom comes from
behind and manages to take him out using
his truck they make their way as far as
possible before it runs out of gas first
off this is why you always read the
signs of a gated fence idiots not
reading clear danger warning signs and
digging around places known for a lot of
buried explosives frankly pops here was
just asking for it which is also kind of
weird since he out of all of them seemed
to be the most capable and let's talk
about that nut job thirsty driver for a
sec i know you gotta pay the troll for a
toll but this is insanity he is a case
example of why i mentioned weaponry
earlier folks and as much as we'd like
to imagine that people in times of
crisis will come together for the good
of humanity honestly that is not a
guarantee people know that in cases like
this the daily rules of life don't
always apply and unfortunately dealing
with people who take advantage of this
is more common than we think the longer
the world goes to hell the more and more
people will start to lose it and not
everybody has good intentions i'm sorry
to say this is also why i mentioned
traveling in groups and why athlete girl
got lucky thanks to mom and her
tag-teaming our thirsty friend over here
find a group if you can and for god's
sake pack some form of self-defense as
mother nature won't always be your only
enemy the next day the group keeps going
on foot seeing mount fuji in the
distance muto and the athlete decide to
take a breather and go for a pee down
the hill but this move is gonna cost
them suddenly the athlete collapses on
the ground and that's when a mysterious
man from the sky warns muto to not go
any further or else she'll die it turns
out that toxic gas is surrounding the
area below the hill the athlete went too
far in which caused her to suffocate and
die on the spot the mysterious man
introduces himself as kite a youtuber
that flies around in a paramotor taking
videos of the japanese landscape he
offers to take one person with him on
his paramotor but everyone refuses
because of this he changes his mind and
decides to join the group leaving his
paramotor behind like an idiot this just
made everything a lot more complicated
she fell harder than a sack of potatoes
and without warning unless she had an
aneurysm or blood clot somewhere this
could only be from some outside force
like a type of gas we don't know for
sure but i'm willing to bet what just
caused this was high levels of methane
gas which is a gas you can't see or even
smell and one that is produced naturally
from the decay of natural material such
as plants and animals which is also
found beneath the seabed the disruption
of the tectonic plates may mean that
this gas could have seeped up and is now
running wild in deadly high amounts a
little by itself is not the worst thing
i know i've tried it it's fun to smoke
it but too much can result in immediate
loss of consciousness and judging by how
quickly our friend passed out i'm
certain it's methane gas while
technically we could have saved her muto
made the right move backing away in time
if anything mom should have sacked up to
save her but let's be real what could
she have done and if we're running low
on food and water then might not be the
worst thing she lived a good life maybe
what i would be concerned with is
watching for wind direction because now
if there's toxic gas around then we need
to try and position ourselves upwind
rather than downwind if possible now i
don't know for the life of me why they
left behind that paramotor that thing is
so useful now unless we know anything
about paramotoring we couldn't have done
much ourselves and this thing ain't like
riding no damn bike if you fall off on a
paramotor whilst in the air you might
die but we could have used kite as a
means to get some aerial reconnaissance
at least while we still had some fuel to
burn it's not like he couldn't have
carried the damn thing whilst not in use
as paramotors are known for the
lightweight engines finding a
supermarket the group scours the place
for any edible goods and useful items
when they suddenly get alerted by a toy
robot that's when arrows start firing
off from every direction giving them the
hawkeye special and then the group
splits up to find cover in the midst of
the chaos go almost gets fatally shot by
an arrow that's when an old looking
grappa comes down from the upper floor
to apologize and offers the group
shelter while they wait out the stormy
weather the next day the group gets
ready to say their goodbyes suddenly
another earthquake hits and both the
group and grandpa are forced to evacuate
the area in his pickup truck the grabba
suggests they go to a place called sean
city a shelter for those who've been
affected by the disaster later that
night the group sets up camp and watches
a national report from the prime
minister the group's plans are
interrupted by a landslide meaning they
need to take another route on the way
they pick up a foreign hitchhiker and
finally make it to sean city the city
welcomes them with open arms and offers
the group food and shelter free of
charge sean city boss man introduces the
gang to their little town but while the
city might seem friendly they're hiding
a much darker secret than no one
realizes meanwhile kite here sneaks out
to go visit grandpa who's sleeping in
his car he slips him some morphine for
his drug addiction but grandpa here is
looking for something much more sinister
and everyone here is going to be shocked
the next day the group checks out a
ceremony by mother the leader of the
city she has the ability to talk to dead
people and communicate to loved ones for
their final words whether good or bad
all she needs is a keepsake from the
person who died however she only
performs this ritual three times a day
kai tries to see just how legit mother
is by handing her glasses guys glasses
claiming it was athlete girls who died
from the methane gas touching the
glasses mother here decides to throw him
a bone and tell him that the object says
it was me who said take a break don't
you worry about it these are the same
words athlete girl said a few days
earlier and now everyone is shocked to
find out that mother might be legit
after all meanwhile everyone has settled
into the city working various jobs and
becoming members of the community muto
here has been assigned as a caretaker
for a disabled man they can't talk and
can barely move however he shows
something very strange by twitching his
thumb and flickering his eyes right
before a minor earthquake hits while
muto might not realize it this disabled
man is going to be very important in the
near future now this cult may be
friendly but i don't trust anybody who
dresses in full white this place looks
safe for now and we've got food and a
place to rest after the day we've had i
wouldn't be complacent just yet delayed
aftershocks can be greater than the
initial main shock with a 5 chance of
this happening within a week of the
initial rumblings earthquake sizes are
largely related to the length of the
fault line upon which the country sits
the longer the fault line the larger the
earthquake and despite japan being right
on top of the johnny cash ring of fire
there is no known fault line long enough
to generate a magnitude 10 earthquake
however what we've seen proves something
is strange which is why i would still be
on alert and trying to steal food and
water from the kitchen during after
hours i know i know this white loving
cult seems safe but we cannot let our
guard down and be ready to move out at a
moment's notice later that night muto
goes to a dance festival held in the
village center it turns out that kite
and glasses guy are there as well and
they're killing it on the dj booth in
the early hours of the morning grandpa
here manages to break into the castle
kill two people and steal mother's kid
and drive out what a crazy old man he
thinks that mother's kid is his own
family because he is high as a kite and
a tiny bit delusional however while
attempting to escape the city he crashes
his truck directly on the gates stopping
him in his tracks locked up for his
actions mother and her team analyzed
grandpa's condition from the security
camera they believe his morphine
withdrawals are responsible for his
crazy antics but they decide to leave
his punishment for later muto here is
looking after the disabled man she
notices that his constant twitches and
blinking might be a sign that he's
speaking in morse code trying to
communicate with the man she uses a
morse code app on her phone to decipher
what he's trying to say suddenly she
realizes that he's trying to say that a
big earthquake is coming and that this
area is dangerous after communicating
with him she realizes that the disabled
man is mr onodera a famous geologist
that predicted japan would sink right
before it happened hearing the news muto
here rushes to tell mom about what she's
just heard the two announced what's
going to happen during the town festival
later that night but no one believes
them suddenly a fire erupts in the
village and the ground starts to break
open and part of the town's statue
breaks off directly onto go but the chef
covers go from the giant debris
sacrificing himself in the process
realizing the danger mother orders
everyone to evacuate immediately in the
midst of the chaos kite here manages to
sneak into grandpa's prison cell
suddenly buzz cut here comes down to
warn them of what's just happened and
tells them to leave the city now however
grandpa still wants to find the child
and decides to head upstairs to find him
buzzcut finds mother wounded from a
gunfight as members are going crazy
trying to steal all their city gold
mother then tells them that they must
find her son before they leave finally
they reach the top of the castle and for
the first time in 10 years the child
speaks suddenly a piece of rubble
crashes down from the roof killing him
instantly grandpa and kite arrive soon
after and explains that his grandchild
died in a landslide and he wanted to
believe that he was the same kid
reincarnated but has come to terms with
the accident getting ready to leave the
rest of the group hop in the truck
however the hitchhiker decides to stay
back telling them he belongs in sean
city and is willing to die meanwhile
grandpa tells kite to leave him behind
in the castle telling him that his days
are numbered the entire building
collapses as the remaining survivors
head elsewhere under a reign of gunfire
and chaos okay we don't have time to
mess around right now didn't i say
something was up if we prepared for this
earlier we could have filled the truck
with provisions like food and water and
left better off the muto and her group
did as of now they have 5 people and no
supplies whatsoever from the fall of
that statue now you get why we couldn't
have stayed in the town to begin with
one of the major problems during
earthquakes is the liquefication of the
earth's soil which happens when the
strength and stiffness of soil is
reduced by the shaking of an earthquake
turning the ground into literal liquid
we've stumbled upon something much more
important the famous paralyzed geologist
he seems to know all about what's going
on and is the only person we can rely on
for accurate information so in
retrospect it's not a bad trade-off and
thanks to muto we found a way to talk to
him i would use this time whilst driving
away to find out everything we can know
about what he knows while he is
extremely valuable he is also a serious
burden this is why i'd get everyone
except the mom driving the car to help
find out everything that he knows this
way we can soon ditch him and not worry
about it the next day the group heads
for the nearest port to board the
evacuating ships there can only be 1 000
people per ship and the whole country is
racing to the ports time is running out
reaching the port the group is forced to
go on foot the line for the ship is
absolutely massive and thousands upon
thousands of people are being rejected
on the spot suddenly mr onodera tells
the group that another earthquake is
coming but what they don't realize is
that this earthquake is going to be the
deadliest of them all lining up muto
here notices one of her coaches waiting
in line alongside her her coach mentions
that the government has given special
treatment to young people with promising
abilities meaning muto here has a free
ticket to board the ship saying goodbye
she hugs her mom and notices something
strange around her waist but ignores it
for now since no one else was given a
ticket she boards the ship but at the
last minute realizes that the fanny pack
her mom was carrying is actually part of
a ventricular assist device meaning she
recently had heart surgery causing muto
to leave the ship and rejoin her family
and that's when all hell breaks loose
mount fuji suddenly erupts forcing the
group back into the truck and destroying
the terrain around them the group
manages to find another port sending
people to safety however this time it
turns out they're only living people
that are purely japanese aboard their
boat meaning muto and her happy family
aren't allowed on board luckily for them
a nice old guy lets them board his boat
setting cell they notice a boat near
them explode in the distance suddenly
shrapnel starts flying from every
direction and pierces the boat the nice
old guy whips out a lifeboat but only
muto go and himself managed to make it
inside while the original boat gets
absolutely destroyed separating them
from their mother later that night the
remaining survivors reached something
strange in the water it's a high-rise
building meaning the whole of japan has
officially sunk alright this is not
looking good we've been sitting here for
what seems like ages and we can't tell
how much time has passed because the sky
is blocked by ash and smoke this also
means that it's nearly impossible for
anyone flying overhead to see us this
group got extremely lucky and likely
wouldn't have made it in any other
scenario we can't use the sun's
reflection through a piece of mirror or
our phone screens to alert any nearby
planes or ships nor from the looks of
things can we use any non-porous
materials like a raincoat to catch and
store drinkable rainwater based on what
muto told us volcanic ash has polluted
the air meaning any rain water we
collect will be unsafe to drink however
desperate times call for desperate
measures so i would carefully consume
small amounts of collected ash water but
only as a last resort since we would be
stranded here for a long time small
amounts of ash taken through the water
in limited quantities could present a
low risk of toxicity in this situation
we have little choice the longer we
remain stranded muto and goher missed
out on a big opportunity to take a break
on top of the sunken building they could
have used that place as a base whilst
they waited out the rescue as this would
have also ensured that they don't get
pushed further out into sea or be at the
mercy of any rogue waves and while this
might sound counterproductive instead of
eating the chocolate bar they should
have fought off their hunger and used it
as bait to catch fish yes you heard me
right according to our friend famous
survivalist michael halworth in his book
the sea survival manual fish are
attracted to vessels and boats this
means if muto had any jewelry on her or
if she used pieces of her phone she
could have used this as a makeshift lure
to attract fish to her area and she
could have used her shoelaces or unravel
sock threads to serve as a fishing line
after a few days at sea the group starts
to get sick and weak suddenly during
that night muto here wakes up and
notices the old guy hunched over the
tent wall with some nice seagulls
viciously attacking him chewing them
away she looks over and notices
something extremely horrifying the man
has been dead for hours and the seagulls
have peeled his skin from flesh suddenly
a shark comes out of nowhere and takes
them away muto here zips the tent up and
the two wait until help arrives after a
few days out on sea mom and glasses guy
here finally find the kids before they
starve to death glasses guy shows them
coordinates left by mr onodera and goher
figures out that they must be located
east of hiroshima using a self-made
compass they figure out exactly where
the closest shore is and head off a
stranded motorboat is then spotted out
of the blue but unlucky for them it's
stuck volunteering to fix the issue mom
here dives in and tries to dislodge the
rope she manages to dislodge it
successfully but before she makes it to
the surface she drowns before anything
can be done okay mom took one for the
team here and this is exactly why it's
good to have people with different skill
sets take turns risking their lives this
way they can get the group out of sticky
situations while we sit back and relax
and since the motor is placed in the
back i'm willing to take a guess that
the boat had a v-drive inboard system
rather than a direct drive system which
would have had the motor placed in the
middle of the boat this means that this
is no easy feat but someone could have
tried reversing the bow just slightly
enough to loosen the tension on the rope
which would have made it easier to help
mom pull out the rope giving her a few
precious extra seconds to swim back to
the surface if this sounds too
complicated then it probably is mom here
is a pro swimmer but her glory days
might be behind her she should have been
able to hold her breath for much longer
and known that swimming rapidly upwards
from deep water to the surface would
cause her to pass out she could have
easily survived the situation by taking
a moment to physically and mentally
prepare her body to withstand the
underwater pressure by inhaling and
exhaling slowly from deep within her
diaphragm we can rid the lungs of low
quality air preparing for it to intake
excess oxygen to be stored within the
blood cells applying this technique for
a few minutes would have ultimately
helped her increase the amount of time
she could have held her breath while it
might seem difficult she only needed a
few more seconds and she would have made
it back to the boat safe and sound some
time later a japanese tank approaches
them suddenly kite appears and invites
them in with mr onodera also chilling
with him as well after a turbulent trip
they finally make it to land and find a
nearby hot spring after a well-deserved
break kite here takes the group to the
only place in japan that can withstand a
natural disaster he knows of a place
with secret archives that might hold the
information to be able to save the
entire country from any further damage
exploring the island they find a secret
cape but kite here decides to go it
alone with onodera walking inside they
find a secret research room with the
files he was looking for as kite manages
to transfer the files into a hard drive
a roaring earthquake then trembles once
again hitting the island as the room
begins to fill with water using an
oxygen tank he and onodera managed to
swim back to the surface but they're not
safe just yet strong waves begin to hit
the island and the hard drive gets swept
away in the process it's dangerous but
glasses guy here decides to go fetch the
files after an absolutely epic sprint he
grabs the data chip and nearly makes it
back to safety he tosses the data chip
to the gang right before a massive wave
slams right into him from the side
killing him if we think about it for a
second he was our best bet since he had
extensive experience in track and field
muto here is also an athlete but her leg
is injured and her only other options
were a kid a youtuber and a paraplegic
meaning we don't have many options
judging from the rough stone coastline
that area looked pretty deadly even if
this guy was a professional big wave
surfer you would have still been dragged
into the stone coastline or the seabed
itself and there's little chance of
surviving that if i were glasses guy
instead of waiting for wave to come and
go and then run i would have begun
running as soon as the waves came
crashing into me this would have been a
little riskier but would have given us a
whole extra second meaning we have 11
seconds not 10 to make it back and an
extra second was all that this guy
needed if he timed it better checking
the archives they find a ray of hope
onodera predicted exactly which areas
would sink as well as which areas would
rise back up meaning parts of japan will
return in coming years using a raft they
find a hot air balloon floating in the
ocean kite manages to fill it using a
spare oxygen tank but the balloon only
has room for one so kite here decides to
fly away on his own leaving the rest for
dead jerk checking mr onodera's body
they find a working phone with a working
internet connection it turns out the
kite used the hot air balloon to find an
internet signal alerting their location
to rescue services and that's when a
helicopter comes and picks them up all
due to kite now they're safe while
looking over the ravaged japanese
landscape muto suddenly passes out due
to the cut on her leg she's taken to the
hospital and operated on a doctor
informs her that due to the infection on
her leg she's developed superrative
osteomyelitis a condition which will
kill her and the only way to stop the
infection from killing her is to
amputate her leg eight years later japan
has risen once again muto here is
competing at the 2028 paralympics with a
prosthetic leg remembering all that
she's lost she completes her dream of
being a world-class athlete marking her
legacy in the history books and if you
want to join the history books along
with muto then i suggest you comment
down below let us know what you liked
what you didn't like don't forget to
give us a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel and also
don't forget to check out our playlist
and our tech talk page